du Sénat français bien
quand vous parlerez
bien bonjour à
à toutes et à tous donc chers collègues
nous commençons aujourd'hui nos travaux
sur la commission d'enquête dans le
cadre de la commission d'enquête Tik Tok
par l'audition de Monsieur Marc Fadoul
chercheur en intelligence artificielle
et directeur de high for & 6 donc vous
direz peut-être un petit mot vous avez
mené des recherches à l'Université de
Berkeley au sein de Facebook vous êtes
aussi directeur de tracking expose d'une
organisation qui étudie l'influence des
algorithmes des réseaux sociaux sur nos
vies vous avez d'abord vous-même créer
des algorithmes avant de on va dire de
mettre vos connaissances au service de
ceux qui qui s'interrogent sur leur
impact sur la société et notamment ce
qui nous intéresse dans le cadre de
cette commission sur les plans
politiques et géopolitiques mais pas
seulement vous avez travaillé sur
plusieurs réseaux sociaux dans Tik Tok
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
choisi de vous entendre aujourd'hui et
pour entrer directement dans le vif du
sujet vous pourrez ainsi évoquer les
caractéristiques de algorithme de Tik
Tok ainsi que la manière dont
éventuellement ce réseau social
favorise certains travers sur lesquels
nous vous interrogerons et vous pourrez
également aborder la question de la
différenciation des contenus proposés
par l'application selon les pays et
notamment se poser la question de la
censure alors pour la bonne forme mais
c'est important je dois rappeler que
cette audition est captée et retransmise
en direct sur le site du Sénat et avant
de vous laisser la parole pour un exposé
liminaire d'une quinzaine de minutes
c'est ce qu'on s'était dit puis après le
mieux c'est encore qu'on fasse des
relances par le biais des questions à
commencer par les questions de monsieur
le rapporteur je dois procéder au
formalité d'usage puisque nous sommes
dans une commission d'enquête et donc
vous rappelez qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête et
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434 13 434 et 434 15 du code pénal et je
vous invite à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure
je le jure et je vous remercie vous avez
la parole pour votre exposé liminaire
nous sommes ravis de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui
c'est bon et bien bonjour et merci
beaucoup de me recevoir aujourd'hui je
salue déjà j'aimerais commencer par
saluer l'initiative de cette commission
qui intervient à point nommé
souvent je pense que le débat sur les
réseaux sociaux et l'influence qu'ils
exercent sur le débat public a tendance
à se focaliser sur la modération de
contenu
et c'est à dire quel poste ou quelle
vidéo vont être enlevés ou supprimer de
la plateforme et quelles utilisateurs
ont potentiellement être bloqués cela
est certes important et la modération
joue en effet un rôle critique dans
l'arbitrage des contenus qui nous
parviennent mais j'aimerais argumenter
que ce rôle est minimal en comparaison
de l'influence jouée par les algorithmes
de recommandation
la réelle question n'est donc pas de
savoir quel poste ou quelle vidéo vont
être supprimés mais de savoir quel poste
est vidéo vont être promus à des
millions d'utilisateurs
la modération du contenu est donc la
partie émergée de l'iceberg quand la
promotion et la démotion algorithmique
qu'on appelle parfois le shadobanning en
anglais ont un impact bien plus
important les algorithmes sont donc
vraiment les gardiens de l'information
en ligne c'est le cas sur Google lorsque
Google stream ou resultat de recherche
c'est aussi le cas lorsque YouTube ou
Netflix personnalisent notre page
d'accueil et c'est aussi le cas lorsque
Instagram ou Twitter font la curation de
notre fil d'actualité et bien sûr et
d'autant plus le cas sur TikTok qui
choisit les vidéos à nous présenter sur
le fameux feed for you qui est
l'interface principale de l'application
le rôle des cruciales des algorithmes
dans la distribution du contenu donc pas
nouvelle mais les particulièrement
prééminentes sur Tik Tok et l'avènement
de cette plateforme a eu le bénéfice de
faire prendre conscience à chacun
d'importance de l'algorithme car sur Tik
Tok c'est vraiment l'algorithme qui est
au sens de l'expérience utilisateur et
je pense qu'on reviendra là-dessus
durant les questions
malheureusement malgré l'immense
influence jouée par par ces algorithmes
de recommandation il reste extrêmement
opaque c'est d'ailleurs là le fondement
de la de la mission de l'association que
je dirige et iPhone 6 où nous analysons
en fait ces systèmes de recommandation
pour s'assurer que les plateformes
soient tenues responsables de leurs
actions face à leurs utilisateurs et
face à la loi
ces efforts de transparence ne sont pas
très vieux à mettre en place
essentiellement parce que les données
qui sont nécessaires à l'anilisme sont
souvent pas disponibles ou en tout cas
sont pas facilement c'est-à-dire qu'on
est obligé de mettre en place toutes
sortes de techniques souvent adverses
pour récupérer ses données
la nouvelle législation européenne le
digital services donne un sorte d'élan
d'espoir à travers certaines de ses
provisions qui vont forcer les
plateformes à mettre en place des
mécanismes de partage de données avec
les chercheurs et la société civile
cela va permettre de réaliser certains
audits en coopération avec les
plateformes coopération forcée par la
loi notamment par l'intermédiaire des DJ
au service coordinateur qui sera sans
doute jouer je pense par la recommand en
France et dont l'un des membres
directeurs Benoît Loutrel je reviendra
témoigner jeudi
nous mettons beaucoup d'espoir dans ces
nouvelles procédures dont les détails
restent à déterminer mais certaines
limites de leur cadre se font déjà
ressentir et elles ne remplaceront sans
doute pas et certainement pas en fait le
besoin d'auditeur qui connecte la donnée
de manière totalement adversaire et
indépendante sans attendre
l'autorisation des plateformes cela va
rester nécessaire ne serait-ce que pour
des questions d'intégrité des données en
fait on peut pas se baser sur des
données qui vont être fournies par les
plateformes purement pour analyser ces
mêmes plateformes
en effet il y a de nombreuses critiques
et suspiciants qui se portent sur TikTok
j'aimerais tout d'abord insister sur le
fait que la plupart de ces critiques et
suspicions restent valables aussi sur
les autres plateformes c'est à dire les
Instagram les Facebook Twitter et
compagnie
on peut noter notamment l'opacité de
leurs algorithmes qui sont opaques dans
dans l'intégralité des cas leur design
addictif qui est fait entièrement pour
maintenir l'utilisateur engagé et le
garder le plus longtemps possible sur
l'application également la collecte
intrusive de données personnelles qui
ensuite utilisé à des fins de publicité
ciblée
et enfin les biais en vert des contenus
polarisants et sensationnalistes qui
sont souvent une conséquence du enfin
qui sont toujours même conséquence de du
design algorithmique qui a pour but de
maximiser l'engagement
il n'y a donc pas de différence
fondamentale entre Tik Tok et les autres
plateformes de réseaux sociaux
ni en termes de design technologique ou
algorithmique ni en termes de nature des
données collectées bien que je
soulignerai des différences importantes
sur ce point dans les questions
notamment en fait la fréquence de
collection des données qui est plus
rapide sur Tik Tok du fait que les
vidéos sont courtes du coup on va avoir
beaucoup plus l'application plus
d'opportunités de collecter de la donnée
qui va ensuite permettre d'identifier
les intérêts niches des utilisateurs
quant à la stratégie à la posture de
l'entreprise j'aime un rappel les que
Tik Tok comme pour les autres
plateformes restent avant tout une
plateforme attirée par le gain financier
qui passe en premier et je souligne ceci
car il est souvent tentant je pense de
penser qu'il y a de l'intention là où il
peut y avoir surtout de la vénalité et
parfois de l'incompétence
Tik Tok comme toutes les autres
plateformes avant tout à faire de
l'argent avant de la politique les
dérives algorithmiques qu'on a tendance
à voir notamment la proportion
disproportionnée de contenu polarisant
ou de désinformation sont avant tout une
conséquence du design de l'algorithme
cherchant à maximiser l'engagement
en effet les contenus les plus
provocateurs ont tendance à générer plus
d'engagement que ce soit parce qu'ils
stimule l'approbation ou la
désapprobation des utilisateurs qui vont
donc avoir tendance à plus commenter à
sauvegarder ou à s'indigner mais tout
cela pour tout pour l'algorithme ça
reste des formes d'engagement qui sont
jugées bénéfiques et donc qui sont en
tendance à mettre en avant ces contenus
de manière disproportionnée
Tik Tok est également une boîte
relativement jeune et d'après les
rapports que j'en ai de l'intérieur
elles restent débordée par sa propre
croissance et ses réticences à investir
suffisamment dans la modération et la
sécurité de ses utilisateurs l'équipe de
trastane Safi est donc comme on appelle
c'est l'équipe chargée de toutes ces
questions et et particulièrement petite
et en fait tout ça reste une histoire de
pour l'entreprise de chercher à garder
des marges élevées elle agit donc de
manière réactive à l'essentiel des
problèmes qui lui font face les équipes
produits ont tendance à vouloir pousser
de nouvelles fonctionnalités avant
qu'elle soit proprement testées et que
leur conséquences ne soient évaluées et
la modération de contenu reste largement
insuffisante et quasiment toujours fait
sous la contrainte
en effet la modération c'est cher et ça
cause souvent plus de polémique et de
problèmes pour la plateforme que ça
n'apporte de revenus et nous notons
d'ailleurs que la qualité de la
modération est quasiment toujours
proportionnelle à la force de et à
l'influence de la pression régulatrice
d'où son importance
elle laisse d'ailleurs encore plus à
désirer enfin si elle laisse à désirer
aux États-Unis et en Europe la situation
est bien pire en Afrique au Moyen-Orient
ou les risques de déstabilisation sont
pourtant bien plus élevés
pour Tik Tok donc comme pour les autres
plateformes c'est la pas du gain qui
reste la cause essentielle de leur de
ces mots
à comparer à d'autres plateformes je
dirais que Tik Tok est plutôt un mauvais
élève mais pas fondamentalement
différent de ses paires américains alors
après bien sûr il y a des critiques
spécifiques à Tik Tok notamment liées à
l'origine chinoise de l'entreprise et
les liens que cela suppose
nécessairement avec le Parti communiste
chinois
des documents ayant fuité en 2020
montrent qu'à une époque les modérateurs
de plateformes de la plateforme avaient
pour instruction de censurer certains
thèmes politiques sensibles pour le
Parti communiste chinois notamment ceux
qui faisaient référence aux
manifestations de la place Tian'anmen
la Chine d'oxygène Pina a aussi montré à
plusieurs reprises qu'elle contrôlait
l'écosystème technologique avec une main
de fer on se souvient notamment de la
disparition de la disparition durant
plusieurs mois du fondateur d'Alibaba
jackma qui sortait un peu trop des rangs
sur certaines de ses positions
bien sûr donc le fait que l'entreprise
chinoise le fait que l'entreprise soit
chinoise et qu'elle doivent de se faire
répondre aux exigences et aux demandes
d'un gouvernement autoritaire constitue
une distinction importante
mais la dépendance stratégique et
technologique de Tik Tok que l'on a
vis-à-vis de Tik Tok et similaire à
celle que nous entretenons avec les
plateformes américaines c'est pourquoi
je recommande que les exigences de
transparence et les réponses en termes
de régulation soit faite de manière
globale pour toutes les entreprises de
l'industrie plutôt que de viser Tik Tok
comme un ennemi à part
nous pouvons souligner l'exemple de
Twitter qui est une plateforme qui
depuis son rachat par Elon Musk montre
plus de signes de manipulation
algorithmique intentionnelles et de
risque d'influencer d'ingérence
politique que Tik Tok
je félicite donc cette commission de
prendre au sérieux la question de Tik
Tok et ainsi que celle de notre
dépendance technologique nous devons
défendre notre souveraineté digitale de
manière systématique en continuant à
s'appuyer sur les institutions
européennes ou la régulation des
technologies a été un réel succès ces
dernières années et où l'Union
européenne a été en mesure d'imposer ses
standards à l'échelle et dans
l'industrie à l'échelle mondiale
merci et voilà je vais laisser la place
aux questions j'ai reçu un Costner très
ambitieux donc je vais essayer de garder
mes réponses courtes pour le début et
puis on pourra élaborer sur les points
qui vous intéressent le plus
merci beaucoup pour votre concision et
pour l'intérêt de vos propos monsieur le
rapporteur va
ouvrir le feu des questions
merci beaucoup moi aussi je insiste sur
la concision qui vous avez été demandé
sur laquelle vous avez particulièrement
été
attentif pour ma part je j'ai beaucoup
de questions dans de discuter avec les
administrateurs mais je vais pas
évidemment en poser beaucoup parce que
je m'imposerai d'autres que si il y a un
manque de questions parmi une de mes
collègues ou est-ce que ça m'étonnerait
je voudrais juste en poser deux ou trois
la première vous venez de dire que le
DSA est une avancée importante et je
crois qu'on est tous d'accord là-dessus
mais et notamment la mise en place des
déesses coordinateurs mais vous avez en
même temps fait remarquer que c'était un
pas mais que il faudrait sans doute
aller plus loin alors la première
question que j'aurais vous poser c'est
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire
quelle recommandation vous feriez pour
qu'est-ce qui manque je dirais dans le
DSA par rapport au problème qui nous est
posé évidemment par rapport à tous mes
problèmes et par rapport au problème des
plateformes notamment Tik Tok est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire ce qu'il faudrait
ajouter au DSA pour qu'il soit complet
la deuxième question que je voulais
poser c'est que lorsque Monsieur le
Président de by dance Singapour s'est
présenté devant les commissaires
européens les quatre commissaires
européens excusez du peu ils ont fait un
certain nombre de de remarques assez
importante assez assez cuisante je
dirais sur les les manques aujourd'hui
de la modération de l'opacité des
algorithmes etc
est-ce que vous connaissez la réponse
président de Tik Tok qui évidemment
comme d'habitude s'est engagé mais
est-ce qu'il a donné des délais est-ce
que
il vous semble qu'il y a une date limite
à demander pour qu'il remplisse
intégralement l'implémentation qui lui a
été demandé par les commissaires
européens
la troisième question
c'est que vous nous avez parlé des
algorithmes est-ce que vous pourriez
nous dire un mot des contenus amplifié
ou cachés par des opérations humaines
c'est-à-dire non dirigées par des
algorithmes en gros les pousseurs si je
peux dire comment ça fonctionne et
quelle est leur part par rapport aux
algorithmes dans la promotion de contenu
dans la censure de contenu
et enfin une question qui est pas
directement lié
à Tik Tok mais qui m'est cher parce que
on en a parlé lors de notamment lors de
la réunion lors de la loi Cazeneuve non
pas dans l'ordre de la loi Cédric o sur
le séparatisme et dans la commission de
la culture et communication
mon sentiment est le Sénat a voté un
amendement que j'avais présenté dans ce
sens il n'a pas été voté à l'assemblée
il n'a pas été présenté à l'assemblée et
il a été voté contre la vie du
gouvernement mais cet amendement
partait de l'idée qu'à partir du moment
où un hébergeur parce que c'est le débat
sur hébergeur et éditeur qu'à partir du
moment où un hébergeur et c'est comme ça
que c'est au point se présente les
gafams
met en place le contenu à partir
d'algorithme fait une curétion comme
vous disiez à partir d'algorithme
évidemment il imprime une ligne
éditoriale à sa plateforme et par
conséquent quent à partir de ce
moment-là il ne paraît plus légitime
considéré comme simplement indifférent
mais comme un éditeur donc avec beaucoup
plus de responsabilités sur ces
programmes et là je passe je pense au
problème juridique qui peuvent se poser
en cas de dérapage je voulais connaître
votre sentiment sur ce sujet
très bien alors
pour commencer donc vous avez évoqué le
DSA et donc en particulier vous me
demandez quelles peuvent être certains
des points qui restent à clarifier pour
pouvoir avoir une peut-être une
transparence plutôt totale le DSA fait
beaucoup de références à la mais
beaucoup de contraintes sur la
modération de contenu peut-être aussi de
ce dont je faisais référence dans
l'introduction un petit peu moins sur
les recommandations algorithmiques si ce
n'est dans un de ces articles où il est
question de risque systémiques pour la
société et la plateforme doit faire une
évaluation de ces risques systémique
dont l'algorithme de recommandation peut
quel algorithme de recommandation peut
contribuer
il y a ensuite toutes ces articles qui
qui disent que les plateformes vont
devoir mettre en place des des apéistes
des interfaces de données pour pouvoir
donner accès aux chercheurs à certains à
certaines données mais il n'est pas
encore clair qu'elles vont être
précisément les données qui vont être
qui vont être mises à disposition à
travers ces interfaces il y a en ce
moment au niveau de la Commission
européenne des la discussion de ce qui
s'appelle enfin les délégated actes qui
vont justement essayer de préciser
qu'elle va être l'implémentation à quoi
va ressembler l'implémentation de ces
articles et il y a également un
un groupe qui s'appelle le call of
practice on discertion auquel les
plateformes ont été invitées
les plateformes ont été invitées de
rejoindre ce groupe de manière
volontaire et en fait le but étant de
détayer un certain nombre de règles qui
si elles sont respectées
donneront une indication positive sur le
fait que le que ça conviendrait aussi
pour respecter le disjon services mais
tout cela reste honnêtement les détails
de concret reste tout à fait à définir
et ce dont ce pourquoi nous nous battons
aussi au sein de de notre association
c'est justement de mettre en place des
critères précis sur le ce qu'on appelle
le reach c'est à dire la la quantité
d'utilisateurs et dans une certaine
mesure la démographie qui peut être
touchée par un certain contenu c'est à
dire que pour bien faire il faudrait que
il y ait des accès
spécialisés si on voit qu'il y a un
contenu qui pose particulièrement
problème parce que c'est une une
parce qu'il contient de la
désinformation ou parce qu'il contient
parce qu'il s'agit d'une ingérence
politique étrangère qu'on puisse savoir
directement à combien de personnes se ce
cette vidéo a été montrée et même
qu'elles peuvent être certains des
démographies de ces
des gens qui ont été touchés
tout cela n'est pas spécifié par la loi
et peut-être que ça viendra en
conséquence mais ça reste aujourd'hui ça
fait partie des efforts de lobbying de
la société civile et qu'évidemment les
plateformes essayent de se défendre
je suis pas particulièrement familier
avec
l'exemple que vous avez cité entre
l'interaction entre le CEO et la
Commission européenne donc je vais
peut-être sauter cette question
mais vous m'avez ensuite posé une
question sur l'échelle on va dire du
contenu qui va être poussé manuellement
sur la plateforme il y a eu une autre
fuite récente sur TikTok qui était
particulièrement intéressantes puisque
c'est c'est un phénomène dont on sait
qu'il se produit mais on ne sait pas
nécessairement son échelle et quel type
de contenu va être touché et il y a eu
en fait une fuite d'un document qui
parlait de heating c'est le terme qui
est employé par la plateforme pour
parler de contenu qui va être
artificiellement amplifié par la
plateforme pour notamment
influencer la culture de ce qui se passe
sur l'algorithme donc par exemple s'il y
a des des tendances qui vont être jugées
bénéfique par la plateforme parce que ça
correspond à l'image qu'ils ont envie de
projeter alors on n'a pas on n'a pas
aujourd'hui de preuve que ça contient
aussi du contenu politique mais la
fonctionnalité existe et l'estimation
était de 1 à 2 % d'après le document qui
a été posté en interne 1 à 2% des vues
donc c'est quand même assez considérable
qui serait faite sur des vidéos qui ont
été manuellement amplifiées l'autre
aspect qui était inquiétant dans ces
révélations c'était que de nombreux
employés en interne avaient la
possibilité d'agir sur ce levier ce qui
peut donc aussi présupposer que ces
employés peuvent être eux-mêmes
influencés de l'extérieur et donc ça
peut être aussi un levier potentiel
d'influence par des acteurs extérieurs
au niveau de la censure c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est difficile à
évaluer de l'extérieur
ce qu'il faut comprendre aussi c'est que
la modération de contenu dont je disais
était certes importantes à l'origine
mais un une des une des choses sur
lesquelles elle influe c'est que le
contenu qui est modéré et par la
plateforme va ensuite être utilisée pour
entraîner l'algorithme de recommandation
lui-même c'est à dire que les contenus
similaires à ceux qui ont été supprimés
ou modérés vont avoir tendance à moins
ressortir et donc ça c'est aussi une
autre un autre aspect important on va
dire de second ordre ou une certaine
censure ou Shadow banning donc
d'émotions algorithmiques peut se
produire c'est à dire que si on a un
contenu qui est trop similaire à
d'autres contenus qui ont été censurés
alors on peut avoir tendance à moins
sortir dans les recommandations
algorithmiques tout ce qui est de le
contenu que
la plateforme va appeler la greyzone
c'est à dire les contenus qui sont pas
illégaux mais qui s'en ressemblent et
notamment les communautés LGBT par
exemple ont souvent
pointé du doigt qu'ils avaient
l'impression que leur contenu était
moins recommandé par la plateforme sans
doute parce qu'il parce qu'il y a des
mots qui sont plus similaires à du
contenu sexuel qui va lui être retiré et
donc du coup on peut avoir des voilà
c'est pas par similarité on peut aussi
avoir de la censure qui se produit
enfin la dernière question était au
sujet de du rôle éditorial quand les
plateformes sur la circulation de
l'information je suis absolument
d'accord avec cette vision j'ai tendance
à dire que un algorithme de comme celui
de YouTube à plus de pouvoir éditorial
sur la circulation de l'information que
celui que sans doute les les
bureaux d'édition des grands journaux
américains ou français
c'est là est d'autant plus vrai que sur
les questions politiques notamment
les plateformes mettent de plus en plus
ont tendance à avoir en réaction aux
critiques qui ont été faits sur le fait
qu'il promovent beaucoup d'informations
de faible qualité ont tendance à
amplifier ce qu'ils appellent les
sources d'autorité c'est à dire des
journaux ou des médias qui sont reconnus
comme étant crédible
et le choix même de ces médias
constituent une inéditoriale évidemment
et
même le choix des thèmes qui vont
recevoir ce traitement de d'information
présélectionnées ou pré filtré
constitue une édition évidemment les
conséquences juridiques sont de cette
distinction sont énormes aux États-Unis
avec ce qu'on appelle la cedea 230 qui
est le texte fondateur qui protège les
plateformes de leur responsabilité
sur le contenu qui est posté par les
utilisateurs sur leur plateforme et
cette distinction est évidemment aussi
importante aux États-Unis
un dernier point que j'aimerais préciser
sur le sujet on a fait peut-être qu'on
en reparlera tout à l'heure une étude
comparative entre Tik Tok et YouTube
durant les élections présidentielles il
y avait la deux stratégies assez
différentes entre Tik Tok et YouTube ou
Youtube avaient tendance à promouvoir
beaucoup justement d'informations
d'autorité c'est à dire de médias comme
France 24 ou des chaînes
d'informations crédible alors que sur
Tik Tok c'était beaucoup plus du contenu
provenant d'utilisateurs qui avaient
tendance à circuler donc on avait moins
cette politique mise en place pour Tik
Tok
est-ce qu'on tourne d'accord alors je
vais me permettre de vous demander une
ou deux précisions et puis on va tourner
comme ça chacun pour ceux qui veulent
poser des questions pour comment dire
aller un peu plus profondément sur ce
que vous avez déjà
mis sur la table
vous avez évoqué la question des
comment dire des applications avec des
algorithmes de manière générale en
précisant même que il y en a d'autres
qui sont tout aussi intrusifs que celui
qui nous occupe ce que vous pourriez en
un ou deux mots nous dire j'ai pu vous
lire par ailleurs vous vous exprimez
parfois le fait que il y a effectivement
des reproches qui sont communs mais il y
a aussi des reproches spécifiques sur
TikTok ça c'est la première question si
tenter qu'il y en ait que vous puissiez
les caractériser la deuxième question
n'est passée
enfin on a évoqué la question de
l'addiction à l'algorithme vous avez
parlé de la rapidité avec laquelle
l'algorithme se je vais pas dire se
forger mais arrive à vous à vous
caractériser
vous avez évoqué je crois dans
différents entretiens en gros c'est
l'affaire d'une heure parce que toutes
les 5 secondes on a une interaction
qu'est-ce qui fait que cet algorithme
est plus puissant et mieux et mieux
formater et pourquoi les autres n'ont
pas eu l'idée avant parce que ça paraît
simple de se dire on fait le plus
d'interaction possible pour recueillir
le plus de données possible donc là
aussi c'est une façon de trouver de
particularité TikTok pourquoi
l'algorithme est plus efficace et est-ce
que vous pourriez nous préciser un peu
cette idée de cyber balkanisation de
l'Internet vous avez évoqué vous-même le
fait de dire si on a une fausse
information
ou quelque chose qui peut influencer
d'une manière contraire au droit à un
moment électoral précis ce qui est
important c'est de savoir qui ça a
touché mais comment est-ce qu'on fait ça
pour et est-ce que ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui déjà est-ce que c'est un
fantasme est-ce qu'au contraire c'est
totalement installé est-ce qu'il y a
déjà un splinternet
réel et existant
alors
en effet donc j'ai commencé sur cette
question de qu'est-ce qui est spécifique
à Tik Tok et vous avez donné je pense
l'élément de réponse le plus important
dans dans la question qui est en effet
le fait que l'algorithme de Tik Tok va
alors on va commencer en fait d'abord
par le design de l'expérience
utilisateur qui est entièrement centré
sur l'algorithme de recommandation et on
va dire avec une vidéo à la fois et ça
c'est assez ça vient dans la continuité
d'une tendance qui existe sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis plusieurs années
mais où sont nés ou en fait si on pense
au premier film Facebook par exemple qui
était en fait le premier endroit où on a
vraiment un fil de recommandation
algorithmique qui va être définir ce qui
est consommé par par l'utilisateur à une
grande échelle on commence on avait
typiquement sur un écran d'ordinateur 5
ou 6 postes visibles à n'importe quel
moment ce qui donnait tout de même une
certaine liberté de choix pour
l'utilisateur de savoir où est-ce qu'il
allait concentrer son attention
le passage sur mobile a déjà eu tendance
aussi à réduire cette quantité
d'information présente à un instant T
sur l'écran d'un utilisateur on voit que
sur Twitter sur Facebook sur Youtube
partout on a une tendance à augmenter la
taille des postes pour en avoir de moins
en moins et donc un algorithme quelque
part de plus en plus paternaliste qui va
décider pour l'utilisateur ce qu'on va
regarder et TikTok c'est entre
guillemets la forme la plus extrême de
cette tendance où on a une vidéo à la
fois et ça ça a deux conséquences déjà
ça la conséquence de diminuer la charge
cognitive pour l'utilisateur c'est à
dire que d'un coup on a même plus besoin
de se demander qu'est-ce qu'on va
regarder on a juste à Swiper un peu à la
on a aussi sans doute une inspiration de
de tinder quoi vous fait vraiment j'aime
pas mais je réfléchis pas trop et ça va
très vite
et l'autre conséquence que ça a c'est
que ça va permettre à l'algorithme
d'avoir une quantité de données
d'entraînement qui est bien supérieur à
celle des autres plateformes et d'une
qualité aussi bien supérieure parce que
pour chacune de ces vidéos qui vont être
évaluées par l'utilisateur c'est-à-dire
toutes les 5 ou 10 secondes en la
regardant en entier ou en passant à la
suivante on va avoir un point de données
d'entraînement pour savoir si la vidéo
en question correspond à son intérêt ou
pas et donc là où en une heure de
visionnage de YouTube on va regarder
peut-être une dizaine de vidéos et donc
fournir une dizaine de points
d'entraînement à la plateforme sur
TikTok en une heure on va donner
plusieurs centaines voire un millier de
points de données d'entraînement qui
vont ensuite pouvoir permettre de
déterminer les intérêts niches de de
l'utilisateur
un exemple qui m'amuse et que j'aime
bien donner c'est que moi après avoir
téléchargé Tik Tok pour la première fois
bien sûr à des fins professionnelles
j'ai l'algorithme à détecté mon intérêt
pour l'algorithme de recommandation en à
peu près une demi-heure et ça ça a
commencé par une vidéo ou un créateur de
contenu parle de que son contenu a été
moins recommandé du coup je m'intéresse
à la question peut-être j'ai un clique
sur les commentaires il y en a une
deuxième sur le sujet également je
regarde les commentaires et tout de
suite il est très facile pour
l'algorithme de détester terminer que à
quel était le point commun entre ces
deux vidéos le hashtag Shadow banning ou
quelque chose en relation avec
l'algorithme et d'un coup j'ai un
intérêt extrêmement niche qui va être
détecté si on passe ça à l'échelle sur
plusieurs heures de recommandations et
sur plusieurs sujets l'algorithme est
vraiment capable de créer un profil
d'intérêt et presque un profil
psychologique de l'utilisateur
extrêmement fin et précis
donc voilà donc je pense que parmi les
donc les les grosses différences on a
bien sûr le la prééminence de
l'algorithme dans l'expérience
utilisateur
la quantité de données qui est fournie à
la plateforme et parfois bon qu'est-ce
qu'il y a comme différence on a aussi le
modèle de viralité qui va être ici
beaucoup moins porté sur le réseau
d'amis donc c'est à dire que sur
Instagram et sur Facebook on reste quand
même sur du contenu qui vient
essentiellement de ses amis ou en tout
cas de profil qui ont été suivis par
intentionnellement par l'utilisateur
donc on a une plus grande
intentionnalité sur le régime
informationnel qui est consommé alors
que sur TiK ToK on va essentiellement
voir du contenu de créateurs de contenu
qu'on ne connaît pas et qui vont juste
être suggérés par rapport aux à
l'interaction qu'on a eu avec la
plateforme
la dernière le dernier enfin notre
élément important je dirais que c'est la
composante musicale c'est à dire que la
base Tik Tok c'était une plateforme qui
était une plateforme de de
lips thinking c'est à dire de karaoké
quoi et de danse et beaucoup de vidéos
ont cette ont une chanson derrière qui
joue un rôle important aussi dans la
dans la viralité et notamment parce que
les utilisateurs on attache beaucoup
d'émotions à la musique et de et de
souvenirs et de et donc du coup ça a
tendance aussi à participer aux
dynamiques de viralité
et à la création de mime comme un
conditionne sur Internet
c'était à peu près
on reviendrait sur le la balkanisation à
l'occasion si vous avez un d'accord ok
je peux on peut voir
moi j'ai pas d'algorithme donc de
manière aléatoire le ou la première qui
se signale
même la présidente j'avais madame billon
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur peut-être juste pour démarrer
les questions hors rapporteur vous
remercier pour les déjà les explications
que vous nous avez données
on sait que Tik Tok est utilisé pour
souvent aller utiliser comme
intermédiaire finalement pour basculer
sur vers d'autres sites d'autres
applications est-ce qu'on connaît
l'ampleur de ce phénomène et
les proportions finalement de ce
phénomène j'avais une deuxième question
sur
il est question de d'algorithme et il
est aussi question d'algorithmes
différents en fonction des pays dans
lesquels l'application Tik Tok est
utilisée pouvez-vous nous dire en quoi
ces algorithmes sont différents et quels
objectifs ils ont puisque s'ils sont
différents c'est qu'ils poursuivent des
objectifs différents en début d'année
j'avais vu qu'il y avait un article qui
disait Tik Tok elle est autorisée des
contenus des contenus pour adultes et
donc ça fait forcément écho à Madame
nous avons fait un travail au Sénat sur
l'industrie de la pornographie donc ça
fait forcément écho à ce travail que
nous avons mené et si Tik Tok
s'intéresse à ses contenus c'est
forcément parce qu'il y a énormément de
clics à gagner d'argent à gagner encore
puisque vous l'avez dit dans vos propos
liminaires Tik Tok et là aussi pour
faire de l'argent donc il est question
d'encadrer l'accès à ces vidéos pour
l'instant évidemment
l'accès n'est pas n'est pas rendu
impossible puisque
nulle part ces vidéos sont interdites il
suffit de se renseigner de dire j'ai 13
ans j'ai 18 ans pour pouvoir accéder à
ce type d'image donc pensez-vous que
c'est ces tentatives de contrôle de
l'âge soit finalement voué au succès ou
à quel à quelle échelle doit-on
travailler pour réussir à contrôler ses
vidéos puisque cette industrie de la
pornographie notamment et forcément une
industrie organisée à l'échelle
internationale je vous remercie
merci
je vais commencer sur sur ce sur votre
première question qui est extrêmement
pertinente vous soulignez le fait que
souvent la radicalisation peut se passer
sur d'autres plateformes on a en effet
on entend souvent parler de ces fameuses
filtres Bull cognitive ou filtre filter
bubble
et parfois il y a un réel débat sur leur
leur importance sur internet je pense
que ce
la lire la littérature en fait
académique sur le sujet est assez nuancé
parce que en fait dans une certaine
mesure l'environnement informationnel
sur les réseaux sociaux et plus variés
que pour des gens qui ne l'utilisent pas
les réseaux sociaux et qui peuvent
peut-être se concentrer sur une seule
source d'information ou un seul média
qui lui n'est pas forcément plus
réaliste
ces études ont été conduites
essentiellement aux Etats-Unis mais où
il y a notamment des chaînes de
télévision qui vont être très orientés
et les gens peuvent avoir tendance à
fréquenter des muscles d'opinion
relativement homogène donc il n'est pas
pour qualifier que les gens sont plus
isolés sans leur perspective
d'information sur internet que dans la
vie réelle cependant les réseaux sociaux
ont une capacité pour
identifier des utilisateurs vulnérables
sur des intérêts niches particuliers qui
est n'existe pas dans le monde hors
ligne et l'algorithme cette tendance de
radicalisation dans l'algorithme de
d'enfermement dans une certaine bulle ce
concentrent vraiment à la marge de la
population sur certains utilisateurs qui
vont être plus vulnérables et souvent
cette radicalisation surtout sur Tik Tok
se passe en privé c'est à dire que
l'utilisateur va être attiré dans la
communauté à travers l'algorienne de
recommandations mais ensuite ce n'est
pas l'algorithme qui va maintenir
l'utilisateur dans cette bulle
l'utilisateur qu'il permet de sortir en
message direct et ensuite envoyer vers
des groupes télégrammes ou vers des des
des groupes de messagerie directe ou
ensuite là il va vraiment y avoir de la
réunion de la du renforcement d'opinion
et une communauté qui va amplifier ces
narrative
donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
l'éducation aux médias c'est vraiment je
pense quelque chose d'essentiel pour
s'attaquer aux problèmes à l'échelle à
l'échelle nationale des très bonnes
associations qui font ça en France
au niveau ensuite la deuxième question
étant le la cyber balkanisation un peu
qui revenait à la question de monsieur
le Président
en effet donc l'algorithme est
extrêmement sensible à la
géolocalisation de l'utilisateur à deux
niveaux c'est à dire qu'elle a joué
localisation vraiment GPS qui va
regarder sortir du contenu très local
notamment en fonction de l'état où on
est aux États-Unis on va pas avoir le
même contenu ou de la région en France
mais il y a aussi une question de
nationalité qui intervient et c'est
d'ailleurs une question qui est très
difficile à définir parce que la
nationalité sur Internet évidemment ne
fait pas directement de sens
ont dans le cas là où il y a eu en fait
un une raison particulièrement
saillante de s'intéresser aux problèmes
ça a été évidemment le conflit entre la
guerre en Ukraine ou nous avons étudié
le contenu qui était promu aux
utilisateurs russes et ukrainiens durant
le conflit
et ce qu'on s'est rendu compte c'est
qu'en fait Tik Tok avait banni le
contenu international pour tous ces
utilisateurs russes et ça ça a été fait
en réaction une loi russe de la fake
newslow Horus qui interdisait en fait
l'utilisation du mot guerre notamment
pour qualifier la guerre et donc il
était en fait devenu quelque chose de
tellement large qu'il était impossible
pour Tik Tok de modérer ses contenus
individuellement donc ils ont été pour
une méthode vraiment assez grossière ils
ont dit on va interdire tout le contenu
international puisque l'essentiel des
critiques viennent de l'extérieur et il
y a plus de de d'autocensure venant de
la Russie sauf qu'ils ont fait ça de
manière complètement opaque sans même
prévenir qu'ils allaient mis en place
cette politique ils l'ont fait que après
la révélation dans le rapport mais on
voit ici que en effet l'algorithme peut
être complètement enfin et assez
spécificités nationales
on peut aussi remarquer que c'est un
détail technique mais c'était pas que
l'adresse IP qui était utilisée pour
identifier la provenance d'un
utilisateur c'était aussi où est-ce que
l'utilisateur avait créé son compte la
première fois donc on voit que cette
notion de d'identité digitale n'est pas
évidente à traduire et qu'en fait c'est
les plateformes elles-mêmes qui
choisissent la définition qui leur
convient donc il y a peut-être il y
aurait peut-être un intérêt à le définir
de manière
dans la loi
et et bien sûr aussi il y a des règles
des règles modération de manière
générale vont être adaptées en fonction
des pays c'est à dire que en il y a
certains pays où il y a
en Thaïlande par exemple crise de l'aise
Majesté c'est existe toujours et du coup
les plateformes adaptent leur modération
pour
censurer les contenus qui vont
critiquer la royauté
donc on a vu notamment durant ce contenu
durant ce conflit la guerre en Ukraine
une cyber balkanisation qui était à une
échelle assez
inédite en termes de où on avait
vraiment du contenu qui était
complètement différente ce qui était
premier en Russie dans le resto du monde
et je pense que c'est une tendance qui
qu'on va sans doute continuer à voir
puisque les il y a une de plus en plus
de pays essaient de réguler ces
plateformes et ils ont tous leur
approche différente et donc du coup on a
en effet une fragmentation de ce qui est
disponible
il y avait une dernière question je
pense sur le soft porn je vais peut-être
j'ai d'abord des très rapidement je
crois il faut se rappeler que Tik Tok a
été je pense une une plateforme dont le
l'avènement et la réussite c'est c'est
aussi fondé beaucoup sur le fait que
c'était une plateforme de soft porn qui
se disait pas c'est à dire qu'ils
mettaient en avant des des personnes
souvent très jeunes d'ailleurs ce qui
faisait des problèmes parce que c'était
pas que des utilisateurs très jeunes
souvent légèrement vêtu souvent
particulièrement attractif sur les
standards de beauté conventionnelle et
d'ailleurs c'était même si on regardait
les documents que j'ai cité un peu plus
tôt ou on disait que les
certains contenus politiques étaient
censurés par les modérateurs ce même
contenu ce même document
donné pour instruction modérateur de
d'amplifier et les gens qui étaient
particulièrement beaux et d'enlever les
gens qui étaient pas forcément tout à
fait qui était pas
ne correspondait pas au standard de
beauté et même de richesses c'est à dire
qu'il était aussi recommandé de pas
mettre en avant des utilisateurs qui
avaient pas l'air aisé
chacun préciser que depuis Tik Tok a dit
que c'est règles n'étaient plus en
œuvre mais c'était elle date de le
document date de 2019
compléter la question si vous le
permettez par rapport vous avez parlé de
géolocalisation tout à l'heure et
j'avais cru voir une information comme
quoi à partir de moment où on avait
l'application Waze justement on était
d'autant plus
géolocalisé avec les plateformes est-ce
que vous confirmez cette information
je n'ai pas la référence précise dans
lequel vous parlez mais l'essentiel de
ces services dont un service comme Waze
qui va être un service de transport à
accès au GPS et souvent il est question
on demande à l'utilisateur de choisir si
on veut donner cet accès au GPS pendant
l'utilisation d'applications ou tout le
temps et si vous mettez tout le temps du
coup vous donnez accès tout le temps
je vous ai vu madame boulespionner
monsieur dossu et après
merci sur le je voulais vous interroger
justement sur le la façon dont vous avez
suivi le conflit donc la partie de
l'invasion russe le Tik Tok russe
comment ça a été changé
les équipes de Tik Tok en Russie sont
basées en Russie ou est-ce qu'il y a une
coopération et le changement que dont
vous avez parlé est-ce qu'il est fait en
coopération avec le Parti communiste
chinois est-ce que c'est les
coopérations orthopédiques d'abord et
ensuite les équipes appliquent les
consignes de la même façon vous avez dit
que certaines équipes pouvaient pousser
un stand de tendance est-ce que ça c'est
géolocalisé c'est fonction de aussi
peut-être de consignes liés à des ordres
qui viennent directement de Chine et
puis j'avais une deuxième question un
peu différente est-ce que le législateur
peut légiférer de façon robuste sur les
algorithmes c'est-à-dire que on a vu que
sur après les premiers scandales
Facebook on a la rgpd qui a essayé de
réguler un peu les données là il y a le
DSA un peu sur les contenus on voit bien
que la problématique des algorithmes
nécess peut-être que législateur se
penche un peu plus est-ce que on peut on
est toujours soumis à la course derrière
certaines dérives ou est-ce qu'on a
peut-être une façon à trouver de de
d'encadrer tout ça de façon robuste et
qui prendrait en compte certaines
dérives à venir j'ai vu que vous
appeliez à construire des algorithmes au
service du bien commun plutôt que au
service des intérêts de la plateforme
est-ce que vous pouvez un peu développer
sur ce type de de vision on va dire
politique des algorithmes qui seraient
moins tributaires on va dire de des
intérêts économiques et plateformes
merci
alors cette question de l'influence
directe des des politiques sur les
décisions de modération
dans le cas de la Russie la décision de
modérer le contenu international en
Russie a été une conséquence de la loi
russe ce qu'on peut appeler une
influence politique directe est-ce qu'il
y a après des tractations dans des
bureaux à porte close avec des
influences de politiciens c'est quelque
chose qui dont je n'ai pas connaissance
je pense bon ça c'est un avis personnel
qu'aujourd'hui Tik Tok n'a pas
vraiment il y a tellement de il y a
quand même beaucoup de regards portés
sur eux et ils ont pas ils sont encore
en phase de croissance ils ont vraiment
beaucoup pas perdre s'il y avait une
interférence qualifiée du Parti
communiste chinois sur les décisions de
modération nous on a essayé de regarder
si notamment sur certaines
histoires comme il y avait donc la
joueuse de tennis qui avait été violée
par un membre du Parti communiste si ses
affaires allaient être étouffées sur TiK
ToK on a vu qu'ils ont pas été il y a eu
pas beaucoup d'engagements sur TikTok
mais il y avait quand même quelques
vidéos présentes il y avait rien de
clair qui disait qu'il y avait vraiment
une une censure directe de de la part de
la plateforme cela dit je pense que là
où le problème pourrait vraiment se
poser on peut imaginer le cas de
l'hypothèse d'une invasion de Taïwan par
la Chine est-ce que on pourrait
considérer que l'information promue par
le sujet par Tik Tok au travers du monde
et impartial je ne pense pas et j'aurais
des inquiétudes sur sur le sujet donc je
pense que ça dépendrait peut-être de de
l'ampleur du sujet et de la et des
risques et des intérêts qui se réjoués
donc voilà c'est des choses qui sont
très dures à
part on peut pas voir de l'extérieur
mais je pense que le risque existe qui
est de l'influence directe
ensuite au niveau de la de comment
légiférer de manière robuste beaucoup de
la législation aujourd'hui se porte sur
la transparence puisque c'est en fait de
manière juste de se rendre compte que
l'algorithme est relativement
responsable et comme je mentionnais dans
le DSA en demande aux plateformes
d'évaluer leur risque systémique sur la
société notamment en termes de
d'addiction et de
promotion de contenu
polarisant
ça n'est pas une solution robuste pour
promouvoir de meilleurs alternatives
vous faisiez référence en effet à une
idée que nous
qui m'est cher personnellement qui est
celle de la souveraineté algorithmique
et j'aimerais
dans l'idéal on imaginer un futur ou ces
plateformes
ont des une obligation
d'interopérabilité sur leur algorithme
ce qui permettrait donc à l'utilisateur
en fait à des parties tiers de fournir
des systèmes de recommandation qui
fonctionneraient sur la plateforme voire
qui permettrait aux plateformes de
marché de d'être interopérable entre
elles et du coup l'utilisateur pourrait
choisir un algorithme qui lui convient
et au lieu d'avoir un algorithme qui
cherche uniquement à le maintenir sur la
plateforme puisque ça c'est quelque
chose on ne peut rien faire quel que
soit la personne qu'on va utiliser on va
avoir un algorithme qui va être là pour
nous maintenir et nous garder engagé ce
qui est pas forcément dans notre intérêt
on pourrait avoir des algorithmes qui
deviennent bien plus à notre service et
potentiellement nous nous apporter de
l'information
intéressante sur certains sujets qu'on
choisit et avec une fréquence on choisit
merci monsieur le Président est-ce que
vous pourriez nous dire quels sont les
conditions d'utilisation à signer pour
s'inscrire et est-ce qu'elles sont aussi
peu lisibles aussi compliquées aussi peu
accessible que pour les autres réseaux
et est-ce que vous pourriez nous en dire
un petit peu plus sur la manière dont
sont collecter les données je vous
remercie
alors les conditions
générales d'utilisation pour être
complètement honnête comme sans doute
l'essentiel des utilisateurs je ne les
ai jamais lu en entier je reconnais
quelqu'un extrait notamment le fait que
personne ne dit c'est bien c'est bien en
effet le problème et et d'ailleurs ça
fait partie je pense de certaines des
je dois pas dire ça il y a pas certaines
de nouvelles obligations pour les rendre
plus plus lisibles justement et
l'une des conditions qui est souvent
nommée problématique sur Tik Tok c'est
que l'utilisateur doit avoir au moins 13
ans ce qui n'est très souvent pas le cas
puisque en fait il y a aucun moyen de
vérification alors parfois je crois
qu'elle a suggestion là d'utiliser
maintenant de une rock'naissance faciale
pour détecter si l'utilisateur à 13 ans
en moins ce qui me paraît encore plus
mauvaise idée
mais
au niveau de la de la collecte de
données de manière générale évidemment
qu'on accepte les termes d'utilisation
on accepte qu'il y ait toutes sortes de
données comportementales qui puissent
être connectés connectés à notre sujet
notamment toutes ces
données qui vont décrire et représenter
l'interaction qu'on a avec le contenu
donc c'est à dire en fait on autorise la
plateforme à développer un plateforme un
profil psychologique et d'intérêt à
notre sujet qui est ensuite réutilisé et
on autorise à ce que la plateforme
utilise ceci pour des fins à des fins
commerciales pour faire du du targeting
publicitaire ce qui est quand même
l'essentiel du business model de la
plateforme
voilà après c'est la collection de
données sur Tik Tok comme je disais et
pas fondamentalement différente que sur
les autres plateformes et c'est
essentiellement ça qui se passe puisque
j'en suis au business model je me
permets de faire un petit point parce
qu'il y avait la question et je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose d'intéressant à
ce sujet là c'est que
Tik Tok et la plateforme pour laquelle
les dons directs au créateur de contenu
sont les plus importants et de loin je
crois que Tik Tok a dégage plus de
revenus c'est je crois 1,5 milliards en
2022 sur ces dons directs que toutes les
autres plateformes réunies et ça c'est
important parce que c'est un modèle de
revenus pour les créateurs de contenu
sur lesquels ils prennent d'ailleurs une
part qui est
inconnu mais qui est sans doute de
l'ordre de 50% donc quelque chose de
vraiment assez massif
et c'est comme ça aussi que Tik Tok
essaye de d'attirer ces créateurs de
contenu sur la plateforme parce qu'il
faut bien voir qui est vraiment une
concurrence aujourd'hui entre les
différentes plateformes pour essayer
d'attirer les créateurs de contenu vers
les plateformes et aujourd'hui les gains
essentiels des influenceurs ne sont pas
sur les revenus publicitaires mais plus
sur le sponsoring ou bien le des dons
d'utilisateur ou bien le sponsoring
officiel où là on va avoir des des
marques qui vont payer un influenceur de
manière officielle pour lui dire faire
la promotion d'un produit ou ce qui est
beaucoup plus inquiétant du sponsoring
non officiel et ça c'est extrêmement
difficile à contrôler et ça constitue en
mon sens le risque d'ingérence politique
le plus fort aujourd'hui sur la
plateforme c'est-à-dire que moi si je
devais je sais pas si je devrais dire ça
au micro mais si je devais faire une
campagne d'influence politique
aujourd'hui
le manière la plus efficace est sans
doute d'aller payer des influenceurs en
sans passer par la plateforme et de leur
dire de faire la promotion de certains
certaines idées ou certains
officiel c'est à dire que c'est déclaré
que et que le le l'utilisateur le
créateur de contenu va dire qu'il fait
la promotion d'une marque ou d'une idée
alors que non officiel ça veut dire que
sous couvert on va dire un influenceur
va défendre une idée politique ou un
produit
merci Michel le président moi j'ai deux
questions donc Tik Tok est avec facebook
l'un des seuls réseaux sociaux avoir
dévoilé une part des secrets de son
algorithme qui reposent sur les
recommandations malgré cette
transparence qui tient lieu d'affichage
publicitaire ou de tentatives de
blanchiment de ses activités nous savons
qu'un album au rythme et vous l'avez
rappelé reste opaque peut-on néanmoins
lorsqu'on en est pas le concepteur en
cerner tous les secrets sommes-nous
capables d'en cerner toutes les
conséquences ou tous les effets néfastes
ma deuxième question est la suivante
Frances hoggans lors de son audition
devant le Sénat avait pris l'exemple de
Facebook dont l'algorithme avait permis
de suggérer des contenus néo-nazis à des
utilisateurs allemands par absence
d'entrave légale à l'intérêt commercial
de l'outil elle notait à l'époque que le
DSA qui entend responsabiliser les
plateformes pourraient limiter ces
externalités négatives donc si je vous
ai bien compris tout à l'heure le DS5 ne
pourra pas inciter les réseaux sociaux à
restreindre cet algorithme donc
pensez-vous que les mesures de ce
nouveau Bouclier européen ne seront donc
pas suffisamment efficaces pour éviter
ce type de contenu
la première question que vous aviez
c'est
sûr le
quand on en est pas le concepteur quand
on n'est pas le concepteur de la commune
alors pour commencer là-dessus donc
même le concepteur de l'algorithme ne
peut pas avoir un une perspective totale
sur les risques que peut déjà de base
sur le comportement que va avoir
l'algorithme dans un certain contexte et
en plus de et même de pouvoir mesurer
l'impact qu'il va avoir sur sur la
société il faut voir que le la
conception de l'algorithme elle se fait
en absence de de données c'est à dire
qu'on va dire moi je vais créer un
algorithme qui va maximiser
le la probabilité que l'utilisateur
s'engage sur un certain contenu mais
ensuite cet algorithme va être dans la
vie réelle interagir avec l'utilisateur
et du coup la création de données de
l'utilisateur et ça c'est pas quelque
chose qui est qui peut être anticipé
complètement et donc du coup c'est pour
ça qu'en fait il y avait aussi une
question là-dessus nous quand on fait de
l'audit algorithmique
plus le but n'est pas nécessairement de
faire du ce qu'on appelle du revers
engineering c'est à dire de d'essayer de
deviner qu'elle va être le code source
de l'algorithme mais plus de d'observer
son comportement donc on n'a pas besoin
de savoir exactement comment il
fonctionne un interne on a besoin de
savoir comment il se comporte et ça
c'est une nuance donc qui est importante
parce que la plateforme elle va être
savoir dire comment l'algorithme est
conçu mais elle va pas être capable de
dire dans toutes les conditions comment
est-ce qu'il se comportent parce que ça
c'est du temps du travail et ils sont
pas les bonnes ils ont pas forcément les
bonnes motivations de le faire si ce
n'est quand c'est pour savoir si ça crée
de l'engagement ou pas parce que on a
toutes sortes de mécanismes pour le
savoir
ensuite au niveau du des contenus
problématique comme les ou racistes ou
là on avait le contenu néonazi promu sur
sur Facebook c'est quelque chose qui est
déjà en théorie interdit
à la fois par les termes par les
conditions les conditions d'utilisation
des plateformes et aussi par la loi dans
beaucoup de pays notamment l'Allemagne
avait mis en place
le une règle
la nette DJ une loi qui était
particulièrement
restrictive en termes de ce qui était
autorisé
à diffuser et surtout en fait qui est
extrêmement restriction en demandant aux
plateformes d'agir très très vite à
partir du moment où du contenu était
signalé peut-être presque trop vite
parce que la conséquence a été que les
plateformes aient tendance à surmodérer
donc c'est là qu'on voit que si la
régulation est difficile à à doser
correctement parce que si on met trop de
régulation la plateforme a juste intérêt
à se protéger mais du coup elle va
enlever plus qu'elle ne doit et
évidemment ça reste un problème qui est
extrêmement présent sur toutes les
plateformes les contenus racistes nazis
ou
et c'est surtout une conséquence en fait
de des communautés qu'on va avoir sur
ces sur ces réseaux qui ont tendance à
être extrêmement vocales
et souvent c'est pour ça qu'on est on
voit ce contenu sur représenté parce que
à la fois l'algorithme a tendance à les
amplifier parce que il se crée il génère
de la critique ou de l'engagement donc
c'est ce qu'on appelle les contenus
polarisants et en plus on s'est des
communautés qui ont tendance à vouloir
se faire entendre et donc du coup à
juste à poster énormément et de manière
disproportionnée
merci mieux merci monsieur le Président
merci pour la qualité de vos réponses je
poursuis un peu la question de Thomas
dessus parce que la la loi qui essaye de
règlementer les algorithmes en France
elle est relativement ancienne elle date
de 2016 de 2016 c'est loi pour une
république numérique dans l'article L
sont je dirais 7 il y a beaucoup de
dispositions le gros problème c'est que
la France n'arrive pas à les faire
appliquer par exemple il y a la
possibilité pour l'arcom d'avoir accès
aux algorithmes des plateformes sauf
qu'on regarde le rapport de l'arcom
décembre 2022 elle explique qu'elle les
a pas et que elle essaye de déduire
de l'utilisation des plateformes le
fonctionnement des algorithmes ce qui
doit être relativement difficile
difficile à faire donc la question c'est
pas tellement celle de législation la
capacité des États à contraindre des
plateformes qui sont partout et nulle
part par définition à respecter un
certain nombre de règles
vous avez cité
l'interopérabilité je trouve que c'est
quelque chose de très très intéressant
mais comment l'organisme et comment
surtout on peut on peut obliger les
plateformes à respecter toute toutes ces
règles je vous remercie
alors je dois avouer mon ignorance sur
le les détails du de la législation
française sur le sujet donc je peux pas
énormément je sais en effet qu'elle
existe mais je ne sais pas dans le
détail pourquoi elle n'est pas
implémentée je sais que c'est également
l'une des grosses craintes du DSA c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a un règlement qui est
en principe très très puissant mais dont
on ne sait pas comment est-ce qu'il va
être mise en place et c'est là que va se
poser toute la question en fait sur son
efficacité et donc j'imagine que le en
effet on est sur des des problématiques
similaires sur le avec le droit français
l'interopérabilité à quelque part
pourrait être quelque chose de plus
facile à imposer mais je pense que c'est
enfin c'est quelque chose qui dont déjà
les implications techniques iraient
assez loin donc il y aurait énormément
de de lobbying et de défense de la place
des plateformes qui diraient que c'est
impossible à mettre en place et que
c'est pas possible
on peut quand même souligner que Twitter
avant son rachat par Elon Musk avait
envisagé de le faire et donc un projet
qui s'appelait blue sky était en train
d'essayer de travailler sur une solution
en ce sens donc c'est bien la preuve que
c'est possible c'est juste que c'est
absolument pas dans leur intérêt parce
que déjà le fait d'avoir un algorithme
fermé permet de garder l'utilisateur sur
la plateforme alors que à partir du
moment déjà une interopérabilité
potentiellement inclut des liens
externes pour le pour la plateforme
c'est un risque de perdre l'utilisateur
et
notamment ça c'est un détail mais c'est
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui sur sur
l'utilisation des Brothers intégrées je
sais pas si vous remarquez mais depuis
un an ou deux quand vous cliquez sur un
lien externe sur une application comme
Facebook ou Tik Tok en fait vous sortez
pas de l'application vous avez un
navigateur intégré dans l'application
qui vous permet d'être sûr que à partir
du moment où vous fermez l'article vous
revenez sur la plateforme changez pas
d'onglet donc tout ça ce sont des des
des
applications font tout ce qu'ils peuvent
pour essayer de garder leur contrôle
moi je connais pas bien Tik Tok je
connais bien Twitter un peu Facebook
mais dont je posais une question est-ce
que on
identifie dans les utilisateurs de
Twitter de Tik Tok la même volume de
l'usine atrol et de bottes que dans
d'autres réseaux sociaux
alors sans doute je n'ai pas les
chiffres mais il est certain que que
qu'il y en a énormément il y en a sur
toutes les plateformes et et il y a
aucune raison de penser que Tik Tok ne
soit plus efficace que que les autres
plateformes pour pour
lutter contre eux puisqu'on voit que sur
les autres c'est une question en fait
d'investissement dans leurs équipes de
modération et système de détection et on
voit que c'est pas quelque chose qui
font dans une échelle particulièrement
grande donc il y a toutes les raisons de
penser qu'en effet il y a beaucoup de
bottes alors après ça va être des bottes
qui vont on va aujourd'hui une nouvelle
tendance c'est la création de contenu
avec des intelligences artificielles
donc qui se développe très rapidement
notamment sur les capacités de vidéos
donc on peut anticiper qu'il va y avoir
aussi une nouvelle tendance de trolling
qui va être sur du contenu généré
automatiquement et donc ça c'est aussi
quelque chose de sur laquelle qui va
quelque facilité
l'implémentation à l'échelle de campagne
de de
comment dit de iNote non authentique et
coordonnées par des par des réseaux
d'acteurs
aussi qui est pas de frustration sur les
questions
petite dernière question mais qui
rejoint un peu celle de ma collègue
Laurence Rossignol c'est sur quand vous
avez parlé des contenus on va dire
extrêmes ou polarisants qui sont plus
visibles est-ce que ça notamment
d'extrême droite est-ce que ça vient
d'une meilleure maîtrise par l'extrême
droite de ses réseaux ou est-ce que
c'est vraiment le la plateforme qu'il
les met en avant parce qu'ils sont
polarisant je pense à l'élection
présidentielle vous avez fait une étude
un peu sur quels étaient les candidats
qui étaient un peu poussés par rapport
au poids qu'il faut peser réellement à
la fin
je pense que les deux phénomènes sont
vrais que vous avez décrit il y a d'un
côté une maîtrise des codes des réseaux
sociaux qui est particulièrement enfin
sur lequel il y a un gros investissement
de certains de certains partis et qui
ont peut-être aussi moins de scrupules à
utiliser des méthodes peut-être moins
comme par exemple pousser des
informations qui vont être fausses qui
de manière générale a tendance à
circuler très bien sur les réseaux
sociaux du fait que quand on voit une
information qui est même si elle est pas
face elle est peut-être juste déformée
elle va tendance à voir plus surprendre
donc on va tendance à
tarder un tout petit peu plus et ce un
tout petit peu plus ou ce beau plus va
être détecté par l'algorithme qui va du
coup
le plus le diffuser alors que si on voit
une information qu'on a déjà Lu 5 fois
ailleurs et ben on va passer sans
nécessairement s'y attarder je pense que
donc là vous référence à cette étude
qu'on avait fait pendant l'élection
présidentielle on avait regardé quel
contenu étaient les plus amplifiés par
l'algorithme on avait vu en effet que
Eric Zemmour était disproportée de
manière disproportionnée dans les
recommandations algorithmiques
aussi en surfant sur une vague qui était
de sur-représentation médiatique qui
était aussi présente dans le reste de
l'écosystème médiatique c'est important
de souligner on va parler aussi beaucoup
à la télé à la radio mais c'était
particulièrement vrai sur les réseaux
sociaux et il y avait même des
utilisateurs qui utilisaient le hashtag
Zemmour pour parler de complètement
autre chose parce qu'il pensait que
l'algorithme seulement amplifié Zemmour
c'était vraiment quelque chose qui était
passé à l'échelle et j'aimerais juste un
dernier point sur cette campagne
présidentielle
on nous avons
fait une estimation basse du nombre de
vues liés à la campagne sur
l'application de 1 milliard donc on a vu
plus de 1 milliard de vues sur du
contenu de vidéo vu sur du contenu lié à
la campagne
70 millions de Français
uniquement sur Tik Tok et Tik Tok a
toujours tendance à
se faire à se défendre entre guillemets
de son peut-être de sa moindre
implication pour modérer le contenu
politique et compagnie en disant que
c'est une plateforme de divertissement
et que ce n'est pas une plateforme
politique ceci est évidemment la preuve
que ce n'est pas le cas il y a
énormément de discours politiques sur
Tik Tok comme sur d'autres plateformes
et même si elle s'en défend elle ne peut
pas s'empêcher d'être aussi un vecteur
de de dialogue politique
merci beaucoup sur le rapporteur
et merci beaucoup pour toutes ces
questions et pour toutes ces réponses
moi il m'en reste deux parmi toutes
celles que j'avais noté
la première c'est que
je n'avais pas noté c'est en vous
écoutant tout à l'heure
vous avez insisté sur le fait que
l'idéal en définitive mais l'idéal c'est
toujours délicat obtenir
l'idéal ce serait si nous arrivions à
obtenir la transparence des algorithmes
et éventuellement l'interopérabilité
mais même sans demander le se demander
le maximum sur la transparence des
algorithmes pour les déesses
coordinateurs dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure par exemple
et vous avez aussi insisté sur le fait
que ce serait la vraie solution pour que
les algorithmes soient beaucoup plus au
service des utilisateurs plutôt qu'au
service de garder les utilisateurs sur
les plateformes ça m'amène à la question
suivante on dit que il y a une grande
différence entre Tik Tok et douillet
puisque douillet n'ont pas des plus
transparents mais en tout cas une
politique qui est beaucoup plus culturel
éducative beaucoup moins addictive etc
avec en plus une réglementation qui
commence qui est annoncé en Europe et
qui pour le moment n'est pas implémenté
celle des 40 minutes sur la plateforme
est-ce que tout ce qu'on dit sur ces
différences entre Tik Tok et dohin c'est
c'est du buzz ou est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est vrai c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'en
Chine l'application a une une façon de
fonctionner complètement différente et
beaucoup plus respectueuse des
utilisateurs et peut-être moins aussi
parce que c'est peut-être il y a
peut-être aussi une un côté
propagandiste après
tout c'est dur de tout le monde ne parle
pas chinois c'est peut-être dur d'aller
vérifier ça et la deuxième question
c'est celle des serveurs
en raison des des nombreuses critiques
qui ont été faites et notamment par
Trump qui a failli faire fermer
l'application
Tik Tok
qui sont le vent du boulet
a annoncer une politique de
d'implantation des serveurs d'une part
en Europe en les concentrant sur les
Roland et en faisant qu'il ne soit plus
à Singapour aux États-Unis
donc en les on est concentrant en
Irlande et
aux États-Unis en les confiant à la
société Oracle
[Musique]
pour
pour avoir pour montrer que les données
ne s'en vont pas en Chine est-ce que
vous pensez
que c'est une solution
ou est-ce que les bacs d'or sont
modifiables comme on veut sont ouvertes
comme on veut et que même Oracle en
définitive à partir au moment où on lui
transmet les données
et capable d'éviter ce qui peut se faire
en amont ou en aval en définitive est-ce
que c'est un une façon de de noyer le
poisson ou est-ce que c'est une vraie un
vrai changement de politique qui
permettrait de
remédier à certaines
certains abus en matière de transfert de
données
pertinentes donc sur le cette il y a en
effet eu cette narrative sur Do Yin
comme quoi do Yin serait une version de
type donc en fait un clone de Tik Tok
mais avec un contenu et une librairie de
contenu totalement différente mais
l'infrastructure algorithmique et
technologique et essentiellement
l'essentiel ce sont les mêmes ingénieurs
qui travaillent sur l'algorithme de
TikTok qui travaille sur celui de
douille en fait que le déploie en deux
versions en deux clones de de
l'application alors évidemment la
politique
de modération et la politique éditoriale
est extrêmement différente en Chine en
Chine on ne se cache pas du fait que il
y a de la censure et le contenu
quasiment intégralement apolitique c'est
à dire qu'il y a peu de gens qui donnent
leur opinion sur des sujets je n'utilise
pas personnellement douille mais des de
ce que j'en ai vu cette
narratif comme quoi c'est du on y voit
du contenu éditorial n'est pas
particulièrement avérée ça reste
essentiellement de contenu de de
distraction c'est à dire des beaucoup de
contenus sur de la cuisine sur des
influenceurs qui aussi promovent une
culture capitaliste et beaucoup de
promotions de produits de choses comme
ça on n'est pas sur du on s'imagine
parfois que c'est voilà les on va faire
que des des reprendre aux enfants à
devenir ingénieurs c'est pas si je pense
pas que ce soit si vrai en revanche il y
a une réelle volonté et une réelle
volonté de la part du du Parti
communiste chinois de limiter
l'influence des plateformes sur les les
enfants en Chine comme avec ces règles
de limitation du temps de de du temps
d'écran que ce soit sur les jeux vidéo
ou ou les plateformes donc là je pense
quand même pour le coup on aurait à
s'inspirer pendant de
ce côté là sans pour autant promouvoir
de politique paternaliste l'État sur les
enfants mais en effet au niveau des des
serveurs et de l'accès aux données
c'est là aussi je préfère ne pas trop
m'avancer parce que je pense que c'est
très compliqué de savoir ce qui se passe
en effet sur ces données une fois
qu'elles sont localisées sur un certain
serveur je sais que malgré le fait que
les serveurs enfin que les
utilisateurs des les données des
utilisateurs américains sont désormais
stockés aussi aux États-Unis il y a
toujours des backup en Chine notamment à
Shanghai
je ne j'ai du mal à imaginer comment ils
puissent ne pas y avoir de perméabilité
sur l'accès aux données même étant donné
qu'on a des données d'utilisateurs
stockées en Europe aux États-Unis
notamment parce que TikTok aura besoin
de ces données pour continuer à
entraîner son algorithme et que
l'algorithme développé en Chine et que
du coup ils vont avoir un moment besoin
de faire accès afin de faire des
requêtes à ces données alors peut-être
qu'elles sont anonymnisées ça va être
des données on n'aura pas forcément le
numéro de téléphone associé mais il faut
aussi garder en tête que ce sont des
données qui sont tellement précises et
spécifiques que c'est des données qui
sont des anonymnisables assez facilement
on a en fait qu'un seul utilisateur qui
correspond à un certain profils
d'intérêt et de comportement et une
adresse IP et toutes ces choses là donc
en fait même les données anonymisées le
sont jamais vraiment
et j'ai du mal à concevoir comment Tik
Tok pourrait se passer complètement de
faire accès d'accéder à ces données et
en tout cas il faudrait leur demander
d'expliquer ça pour pouvoir les que ce
soit en argument crédible
je crois qu'on est arrivé au bout de
l'audition merci infiniment du temps que
vous nous avez consacré l'ensemble des
éclairages voilà merci à toutes et à
tous merci à vous